j'espère que ceux qui sont restés au
fond de leur lit la dernière fois où à
peu près écoutez ou appris ce que j'ai
racontée parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est en
prendre la suite
et je vous rappelle ce que j'ai dit à
vos copains puisque c'est
essentiellement à ceux qui étaient au
fond de leur lit qui était destinée qu
en ce qui me concernait c'était très
exactement pas mon problème que vous
coucher à l'heure que vous voulez que
c'est pas une raison pour parvenir en
cours le lendemain si un jour vous vous
décidez d'aller pauvres ne pas aller au
boulot quand vous serez payé pour ça je
pense que vous pourrez expliquer tout ce
que vous voulez sur l'heure à laquelle
vous êtes couché la veille
ça ne changera strictement rien un
manière dont votre patron vous regardera
bon sur ce on est reparti la dernière
fois je vous ai donc parlé du changement
climatique delà de la physique qui était
à l'oeuvre et de ce qu'on pouvait avoir
comme grandes catégories de conséquence
donc en fait c'est ce genre de choses
dont on va refaire une revue de détail
aujourd'hui en regardant les choses un
peu plus en détail pendant la répétition
on va donc regarder ce qu un climat qui
se modifie rapidement pour abonné et je
dis bien pourrait donner sur un certain
nombre de dévolution qui nous touche de
plus ou moins très et pendant les deux
heures dont on va parler de ce genre de
choses aujourd'hui garder surtout en
mémoire la dernière phase de
transparence c'est-à-dire que je vous
rappelle encore une fois et j'insiste
énormément là dessus que quand vous
faites pour la première fois une
expérience grandeur nature sur un
système sur lequel vous changer
énormément de paramètres par rapport à
ce que vous avez l'habitude de regarder
vous êtes raisonnablement assurés qui se
passera tout sauf ce que vous avez en
tête donc le changement climatique va
produire des tas d'effets et le monde
tel que lu tel qu'il se présentera aux
yeux de nos proches descendant en 2050
ou en 2100 il va ressembler à tout se
passe qu'on imagine aujourd'hui ça ne
veut pas dire qu'on ne court pas de
risque
ça ne veut pas dire qu'il va rien se
passer ça veut simplement dire que
jouèrent elizabeth teissier est un
exercice qui n'a aucun sens
le
n'est pas déterminé il n'est pas
déterministe donc il va se passer des
choses on peut en donner des grandes
caractéristiques
ça n'aurait pas de sens d'essayer de
faire une prévision exact la première
chose que je vais vous rappeler
et cette fois ci je vais vous le
rappeler de manière un peu plus précise
que la dernière fois où un peu plus
régionaliser que la dernière fois
c'est que le climat qui que le système
planétaire connaîtra dans 50 ou 100 ans
il va être pour une large partie
dépendant de ce que nous allons faire
dans les décennies qui viennent et en
particulier de la quantité d'énergie
fossiles que nous allons utiliser en
envoyant le co2 dans l'atmosphère
les trois otages deux graphiques que
vous avez sur ce transparent
représentent les élévations régional de
température possible alors c'est à
prendre au sens du sommet de la
gaussienne la danse que vous avez montré
la dernière fois donc les élévations de
température possible avec le scénario
bas des émissions qui concerne le bas de
la fourchette avec lequel les physiciens
travail d'une des émissions constante ou
quasi constante
ici vous êtes dans le cas de figure des
émissions avec scénario charbon eux donc
des émissions qui doivent le d'ici à
2050 et baisse ensuite
et là vous avez des émissions en
fonctionnement la réaction du système
climatique à des émissions qui
quadruples sur le courant du siècle
quelques enseignements absolument
majeurs sont à retirer de ces graphiques
que vous voyez actuellement on va
commencer par la colonne de droite c'est
à dire la différence entre les
températures régional moyenne
aujourd'hui et les températures régional
moyenne de la dernière décennie du 21e
siècle et vous voyez on retrouve un
certain nombre de conclusions quelle que
soit l'ampleur de l'élévation de
température
la première des conclusions qu'on
retrouve c'est que l'élévation au dessus
des océans et tamponné par l'inertie
thermique de ces derniers et elle est
donc moins rapide que l'élévation au
dessus des continents
la deuxième chose que vous voyez se
matérialiser dans ces trois graphiques
c'est que l'élévation est
particulièrement rapide près du pôle
nord
c'est là que ça va le plus vite et alors
ça c'est la conjonction de
plusieurs processus le premier ce que je
vous ai expliqué la dernière fois c'est
que le taux de fer étant une
interception du rayonnement infrarouge
terrestre son élévation se manifeste de
manière plus ample quand ya pas de
soleil que quand il en a donc on
s'attend assez logiquement à ce que près
des pôles où il ya pas beaucoup de
soleil et bien l'élévation
l'intensification de l'effet de serre
produisent un effet relatif plus marquée
que aux tropiques
là vous avez déjà beaucoup de soleil une
deuxième cause et cela c'est que peut il
fait froid donc l'airé sec et à partir
du moment où vous rajoutez un peu de co2
dans l'atmosphère l'effet direct du co2
est décelable
alors que l'autre pic où l'air est déjà
sûre saturé d'humidité exactement à
l'équateur eh bien vous avez vous
rajoutez un peu de co2 dans l'atmosphère
et même élever un peu la température de
l'air
l'effet de serre additionnel qui en
résulte est proportionnellement beaucoup
moins important ensuite vous avez un
troisième facteur qui explique le fait
que ça va monter particulièrement fort
près du pôle nord
c'est que ça la montée plus fort sur les
continents que sur les océans comme j'ai
dit et donc ça va monter plus vite dans
l'hémisphère nord qui est un hémisphère
très continental que dans l'hémisphère
sud qui est un hémisphère plus océanique
quatrième facteur c'est que vous avez
une rétroaction sur la glace de mer
c'est à dire la banquise la banquise va
sont étendus estivale va diminuer dans
le courant du siècle et donc on va
remplacer une surface particulièrement
réfléchissantes la banquise par de l'eau
océanique beaucoup plus absorbantes et
ça ça va entraîner un effet
d'amplification du réchauffement près du
groenland
cet effet doit être beaucoup moins
marquée au pôle sud où l'essentiel de la
glace est une calotte permanente c'est
la calotte antarctique qui ne sera pas
affecté par le réchauffement du 21e
siècle
donc tous ses effets conjugués vous
explique
et c'est une conséquence car enius avait
déjà comprises qualitativement et un
siècle
tous ces effets conjugués vous explique
que le réchauffement va être
particulièrement marquée dans le pôle
nord et plus vous allez en avant dans
l'hémisphère nord et plus vous allez
vers le pôle plus il sera marqué
évidemment l'ampleur du réchauffement en
dépend elle de la quantité de gaz à
effet de serre on va rajouter dans
l'atmosphère d'ici 2100 maintenant une
dernière conséquence vous voyez pardon
un dernier
ni point important c'est que ici le
scénario médian là à un dé qui conduit à
une élévation de température planétaire
qui se promène aux alentours de 3 degrés
plus ou moins quelque chose eh bien vous
voyez que la certaines zones de la
planète où ça peut vous donner du plus
quatre du plus 5 voire de +6 ou de plus
cette élévation de température ne sera
pas du tout homogène en fonction de la
zone où vous allez vous situez une autre
conséquence et on reviendra dessus un
peu plus tard vous voyez que sous le
groenland ici vous avez quel que soit le
scénario retenu un endroit où ça chauffe
beaucoup moins qu'ailleurs dans tout
l'hémisphère nord et en particulier est
presque pardon ça chaufferait moins que
partout ailleurs sur la planète
vous avez ici la traduction du
ralentissement de la circulation de la
d-league dans l'atlantique sur lequel je
reviendrai tout à l'heure alors ça ne
sera pas le seul après pour ceux d'entre
vous qui ont vu ce film
mais ça pourrait induire des
modifications significatives dans le
système climatique ouest européen ici
vous avez d'élévation de température
planétaire régionaliser aussi sur les
trente ans exactement par rapport à la
différence entre maintenant et de 30 ans
en moyenne et vous voyez là quelque
chose d'absolument majeur qui est que
cette élévation de température
elle est largement indépendantes du
scénario qui essuie en d'autres termes
ce que va devenir le climat sur les 30
ans qui viennent c'est déjà scellé ou à
peu près celle et les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre que l'humanité se
rassurent les 30 ans qui viennent vont
avoir une influence absolument majeur
sur le climat dans lequel vivront vos
enfants ça n'aura que très peu
d'incidence sur le climat dans lequel
vous allez vivre vous bien évidemment
avec ce que je vous ai raconté sur la
première partie de secours sur l'énergie
ya quand même un intérêt économique
évident à se dépêcher d'économiser
l'énergie fossile
avant même d'attendre 2030 mais ce qu'il
faut comprendre là c'est que quand on
agit sur enfin quand on consomme moins
d'énergie
l'effet est un relativement court terme
sur le système socio-économique sur le
système climatique
il ya un décalage de plusieurs décennies
avant que vous commenciez à en voir les
effets de manière évidente
première question que on va tous se pose
est est-ce que domination deux dernières
décennies et déjà la conséquence de
l'augmentation de l'effet de serre
alors je vous ai répondu la dernière
fois à l'occasion d'un graphique que je
vous avait projeté voici quelque chose
qui revient sur ce que je vous avais
raconté c'est à dire que sur les
dernières décennies probablement oui
vous avez ici une cartographie des
évolutions régionales de température
depuis 1979 jusqu'à 2005
évidemment plus sérieuse plus ça va
chauffer de manière importante
vous avez des endroits à tous les blancs
ou n'a pas assez de données pour
construire non sur le sens de
l'évolution et vous voyez qu'on retrouve
dans les grandes lignes ce qui est
attendu pour le siècle à venir en terme
de variation régional de température
vous voyez que ça monte plus fort sur
les continents que sur les océans
globalement cela vous ne voyez pas bien
sur cette carte mais c'est là que ça
montre le plus fort les élévations de
température les plus prononcés sur cette
carte ont lieu au dessus du groenland
j'ai quelque chose de tout à fait
attendu et vous voyez que par contre aux
tropiques on a plutôt tendance à avoir
des élévations de température moins
marquée que quand on remonte en latitude
donc ce qui s'est passé sur les trente
dernières années est quelque chose qui
est vraisemblablement comme je le disais
la dernière fois déjà la marque de
l'effet de serre avant même de savoir si
c'est la marque de l'effet de serre il
ya des élévations de température qui
sont parfaitement caractérisés par un
grand gars de la france par exemple il
ya eu une élévation de température très
net sur le 30 dernières années avant
c'est beaucoup moins évident question
encore une fois est-ce que c'est nous
est-ce que c'est padoue alors je vous ai
dit la dernière fois que personne
observait une température moyenne devant
sa porte
donc nous tout ce qu'on sait observer ce
sont des conditions instantanée et
locales et je vous rappelle encore une
fois que la france grand pays par son
rayonnement ne fait qu'un pour mille de
la surface planétaire et que un mois
c'est par définition un douzième d'une
année qui est elle-même un trentième du
patron
on retient généralement pour définir un
climat un donc un deuxième fois un
trentième normalement sauf si vous êtes
très endormi vous êtes encore capable de
ça ou alors que ça fait à peu près un
360e donc il est bien évident que ce qui
se passe sur un mois en france
un millième de la surface planétaire
c'est quelque chose qui n'a pas de
signification particulière sur la
variation de la moyenne de bien faire
froid ou chaud à me donner ça n'a pas de
signification particulière sur la
variation de la moyenne mais ici donc
pour en revenir à ce que je disais une
élévation marquée de la moyenne
vous voyez aussi que par exemple l'année
2003 que vous avez ici a été presque
aussi chez de l'année 1994 ou presque
aussi chaude que l'année 2006 à leur
2006 est un tout petit peu restée dans
les mémoires parce que ça s'est passé
après 2003 donc les gens maintenant
commence à guetter les coups de chaud
par contre en 1994 ce qui s'est passé
n'avait pas suscité autant d'attention
alors que ce que en 2003 il a eu quelque
chose de particulier outre le fait que
la moyenne a été particulièrement élevé
il ya la réponse est oui c'est que vous
avez eu une grande variabilité de la
moyenne saisonnière et c'est quelque
chose que tout à l'heure on va étendre
d'une manière un peu plus générale il ya
deux choses comme je disais la dernière
fois qu'ils sont importants dans
l'évolution du système climatique
il ya la variation de la moyenne et la
variation de l'écart type
et là vous avez une année typique où
l'écart type a été particulièrement
important c'est à dire que d'un mois sur
l'autre
on a connu des écarts à la moyenne qui
ont pu aller dans un sens et dans
l'autre avec une très grande variation
entre les deux 2003 a commencé par deux
mois qui ont été significativement plus
froid que la moyenne est du reste ya eu
en mars et en avril alors là ça paraît
moins mais des gelées tardives qui ont
fait énormément de dégâts dans les
cultures et les viticulteurs par exemple
qui ont beaucoup souffert de la canicule
de juin et 2 août ont encore plus
souffert des jeunes est tardive qui a eu
qui ont eu lieu en mars
un moment où la végétation avaient déjà
des bruits ça a été exactement la même
chose en ce qui concerne les fruitiers
qui ont aussi eu droit d ailleurs qu
elle durer cette année là donc 2,3 à
commencer par deux mois plus tôt et plus
fort que la moyenne et ça n'a absolument
pas empêché que quelques mois après vous
ayez eu deux mois considérablement plus
chaud que la moyenne
donc il faut bien voir qu'une moyenne
encore une fois ça masque les variations
et la variabilité
or la variabilité peut faire des dégâts
absolument considérable à une élévation
moyenne est quelque chose qui en général
fait moins de dégâts qu'une augmentation
forte de la variabilité pour traduire le
pour vous donner une idée de ce que
signifie en termes d'événements
climatiques ou des deux vagues de
chaleur possible un déplacement de la
moyenne planétaire de quelques degrés je
vais utiliser cette petite courbe qui
vous donne la distribution de
températures estivales en suisse entre
1864 et 2003 donc on va dire en gros sur
un siècle et demi alors vous voyez que
la suisse pays encore plus petit que la
france par sa superficie est encore plus
grand par son rayonnement à une
température d'été qui en gros se promène
aux alentours de 15 degrés la moyenne
des températures d'été est à peu près de
15 degrés un devis septembre 17 plus ou
moins 1 on va dire que c'est l'essentiel
des des températures estivales
et puis en 2003 vous avez un été
complètement inhabituelles voyez tout à
fait en dehors de lagos yen qui se
trouve à 5 degrés de la normale et bien
pour que cet été 2003 devienne la
normale il suffit que la température
planétaire g de 3° peut-être 4 si vous
avez la température planétaire qui
grimpe de 3 degrés je vous ai dit tout à
l'heure au dessus des continents sera
tendance à grimper un peu plus vite
les simulations vous explique que sur le
construire du bassin méditerranéen et en
particulier
et ça pour ça pourrait monter encore
plus vite et à ce moment vous vous
retrouvez avec des températures
estivales dans le sud de la france on va
dire avec lesquels vous avez trois demis
quatre et demi doit vous vous êtes dans
le 4 à 5 degrés en plus parce que tout
ce qui est à l'intérieur là c'est plus
de 4 et la semaine à l'été 2003 n'est
plus très loin de devenir l'été normal
alors le thé normal ça veut dire qu un
été sur deux plus chaud ça veut dire que
quand vous avez une excursion de
température vers le haut vous pouvez
avoir un été significativement plus
chaud que l'été 2003 alors en été 2003
vous avez cent mille hectares de forêts
qui ont disparu vous avez un certain
nombre d'endroits où s'il n'y avait pas
eu des camions pour amener du foin les
aviculteurs perdait la chapelle etc
et c'est donc dans un monde dans lequel
ce genre de truc n'arrive pas trop
souvent et avec plein d'énergie
abondante pour y faire face c'est pas
trop un problème si vous vous retrouvez
dans un monde dans lequel ce genre de
truc arrive tous les deux ans avec
beaucoup moins d'énergie abondante ça
deviendra beaucoup plus un problème
anglais ce que je suis en train de vous
dire c'est que un simple déplacement de
la moyenne
est-ce que ça c'est très exactement ce
que j'ai illustré ici c'est un simple
déplacement de la moyenne est déjà
quelque chose qui pourrait poser des
problèmes de manière significative
en gros si vous regardez votre
distribution et que vous considérez que
tout ce qui dépasse un certain seuil
pose problème eh bien vous voyez que si
par exemple celle qui pose problème est
ici dans l'ancienne distribution là le
pourcentage des événements qui pose
problème c'est cette surface dans la
nouvelle distribution
c'est une surface considérablement
augmenté donc vous avez une fraction
considérablement plus important
d'événements qui vont se mettre à poser
problème
dans le même temps vous pouvez avoir
aussi une augmentation de la variabilité
c'est à dire que vous tapez sur votre
goût sienne et à ce moment vous arrivez
dans une situation particulière ou non
seulement vous continuez à avoir de
temps en temps des épisodes très froid
qui ne sont pas la marque d'une moyenne
qui ne s'est pas déplacé c'est
l'occurrence un qui détermine ça mais
c'est pas la marque
en soi d'une moyenne qui ne s'est pas
déplacé et à ce moment vous avez un
accroissement encore plus significatif
des événements qui dépassent un certain
seuil à la hausse donc la mauvaise
situation
c'est quand vous avez non seulement un
déplacement de la moyenne mais également
une augmentation de la variabilité
alors maintenant on peut regarder ce que
ça donne pour les températures estivales
en europe et vous voyez pas de chance a
priori on devrait avoir les deux c'est à
dire à la fois un déplacement de la
moyenne et une augmentation de la
variabilité c'est à dire que quand il ya
un épisode caniculaire il n'est pas 5
degrés au dessus de la moyenne il peut
être si si peut être cette île peut être
8 il est évident on y reviendra tout à
l'heure mais il est évident que un monde
dans lequel l'été 2003 devient la norme
est un monde dans lequel vous pouvez
probablement dire adieu à une large
partie de la forêt française
il est évident que c'est un monde dans
lequel très rapidement les agriculteurs
se met à avoir des problèmes etc etc
j'ai dit agriculteurs il faut donc que
je parle de précipitation car un climat
ça n'est pas seulement une température
moyenne s'est aussi des précipitations
ici vous avez un graphique alors les
graphiques de l'eee pc ou du giec sont
toujours des graphiques extrêmement
riche en informations on a l'impression
que c'est simple comme ça mais en fait
il ya énormément de choses le graphique
de gauche
ici vous donne l'évolution sur la
dernière décennie du 21e siècle par
rapport aux deux dernières décennies du
xxème siècle des précipitations
pour la période décembre janvier février
donc c'est ce qui correspond à l'hiver
sous nos latitudes sur ce graphique
là où les couleurs sont rouges ou
orangés c'est que vous avez un déficit
de précipitations dans un siècle par
rapport à maintenant et la l2 couleurs
sont bleus c'est que vous avez un
surplus alors quand je dis vous avez un
déficit vous avez un surplus comment
est-ce que ça doit se comprendre ce
résultat
ça doit comprendre de la manière
suivante je prends les vingt ou trente
modèles dont je vous ai parlé la
dernière fois je les fais tous tourné
avec une hypothèse commune qu'il a en
l'occurrence et mon scénario charbon eux
et je regarde si les simulations que
j'obtiens s'accordent sur l'évolution
régionale des précipitations
90% des simulations que j'effectue
s'accordent à la fois sur le sens et sur
l'amplitude je mets des pointillés
si j'ai tout le monde qui s'accordent
sur le sens mais pas sur l'amplitude je
mets une couleur mais pas de pointillés
et si je suis dans des zones dans lequel
personne n'est d'accord c'est à dire que
j'ai trois modèles qui disent c'est
beaucoup plus d'eau qui disent c'est un
peu plus 3 qui disent c'est beaucoup
moins et quatre qui lisent c'est un peu
moins 1 et 2 qui disent ça bouge pas à
ce moment je mets du gland ça veut dire
je ne sais pas
étant entendu que à chaque fois qu'un
scientifique va vous dire je ne sais pas
ça veut pas dire que on risque rien je
veux dire je ne sais pas c'est juste ça
que ça veut dire si j'ose aux 2 5 mètres
de haut est ce que je me casse la
colonne vertébrale
je ne sais pas dire que je ris que rien
là c'est très exactement comme ça qu'il
faut comprendre quand on sait pas c'est
à dire qu'on risque rien tudor
conséquent je reprends donc ce que je
vous expliquais don comprend 1 une
vingtaine d'outils de simulation du
système climatique
on les fait tourner avec des émissions
de gaz à effet de serre ou les émissions
passent progressivement par le double de
ce qu'elles sont aujourd'hui avant de
redescendre un peu et à ce moment là
moyenne des simulations qu'on obtient
vous dit globalement il se met à
pleuvoir plus l'hiver sous nos latitudes
près du pôle nord
il se met à pleuvoir - l'hiver aux
tropiques il se met à pleuvoir plutôt
plus l'hiver en équateur et puis de
l'autre côté c'est un peu symétrique
c'est à dire que il se met à pleuvoir -
alors chez eux c'est plutôt l'été aux
tropiques est plus près du pôle en gros
vous avez une intensification l'hiver
mais ça marche aussi l'été comme vous
pouvez le constater sur l'autre image
qui vous montre la même chose pour les
mois de juin juillet et août
vous avez raté une intensification des
parents existantes
donc là il ya déjà beaucoup de pluie il
pleut plus tôt plus et là où vous n'avez
pas beaucoup de pluie il pleut il pleut
plus tôt - je vais y arriver ça
s'explique avec les mains de manière
assez j'allais dire assez
assez intuitive il se trouve que les
précipitations c'est pour partie le
résultat de la convection à grande
échelle que vous avez dans l'atmosphère
vous avez un grand processus de
convection à 100 fin de leur mouvement
ascendant près de l'équateur
et puis un grand mouvement de subsidence
aux tropiques
c'est ce qu'on appelle les cellules de
hadley et quand vous intensifier cette
conviction
globalement il pleut plus tôt plus là
vous avez le courant ascendant et il
pleut plus tôt - là vous avez le courant
décembre
vous voyez que la france est située dans
une zone où on va dire sa façade
méditerranéenne devrait connaître un
assèchement en toutes saisons lurette
devrait connaître un assèchement marqué
l'été est là dessus tout les simulations
semblent d'accord pour le moment vous
avez un certain nombre d'endroits où il
se passe des choses qui pour le moment
sont mal cernés à la nouvellle et que
par exemple sur le bassin amazonien vous
devriez avoir plutôt un assèchement
quand c'est l'été chez nous donc l'hiver
chez eux par contre quand il était chez
eux c'est difficile de savoir ce qui se
passe
vous avez que pour le moment il n'y a
pas de résultats convergents alors ça
c'est quelque chose d'absolument majeur
parce qu'il se trouve que la majeure
partie des écosystèmes sont beaucoup
plus sensibles précipitations qu'aux
températures et le devenu à du bassin
amazonien et quelque chose qui va être
absolument central dans l'avenir du
système climatique et je vous en
parlerai un petit peu après sur la
manière dont les deux sont couplés l'un
à l'autre vous verrez également dans la
zone de bouchons au dessus de l'asie ici
est bien heureux on a tendance à voir
les extrêmes s'exacerber c'est à dire
que quand on est en saison sèche c'est
plutôt plu c'est que quand on est en
saison humide c'est plutôt plus humide
ce qui veut dire bien évidemment que ça
peut poser des problèmes mais ma
précipitation global sur l'année
constante parce que vous avez pendant la
saison sèche le sol qui s'assèchent plus
et qui se durcit et au moment où on
arrive et quand il entend beaucoup elle
part directement à la mer parce que sur
un sol extrêmement sec l'eau pénètre mal
et donc vous pouvez très bien avoir avec
des précipitations qui sont constantes
un assèchement du sol et donc des
conditions qui sont ma propre moins
propice pour que les plantes y poussent
ici vous avez quelque chose qui est le
pendant des précipitations alors faites
attention les couleurs ont été mal
choisie on aurait dû les choisir dans le
sens inverse
c'est non pas l'évolution des
précipitations mais c'est l'évolution de
l'évaporation
donc si vous voulez savoir ce qui reste
sur ou dans le sol
eh bien il faut faire le bilan ce qui
tombe - qui repart sous forme
d'évaporation
ici vous avez l'évolution donc de
l'élaboration on va dire à l'échelle du
siècle
je veux que globalement cette
évaporation et la tendance à augmenter
un peu partout sur le sahara déjà pas
extrêmement élevé et celle sur le
pourtour face au sud du groenland à ceci
expliquant cela
c'est à dire que vous avez ici la
traduction du nom réchauffement voire du
léger refroidissement global que vous
devriez avoir au sud du groenland à
cause du ralentissement de la
circulation océanique de balle et vous
voyez donc on a globalement ici à perdre
des décorations qui va s'intensifier et
ça veut dire que l'humidité des sols
elle va évoluer comme la résultante de
ce qui tombe - ce qui c'est l'apport ou
ski par la mer évidemment est ici vous
avez l'évolution à kindu du degré
d'humidité des sols
d'ici un siècle alors c'est toujours
pareil ainsi la comparaison de la
dernière décennie du 21e siècle avec
deux dernières décennies du xxème siècle
dans le scénar le charbon donc là à un b
par contre y'a pas de couplage est le
cycle du carbone je vous dirai pas ce
que ça veut dire et vous devez mieux que
dans la quasi partie du pourtour enfin
dans la quasi-totalité pardon du
pourtour du bassin méditerranéen
on devrait voir un assèchement des sols
ce qui globalement est pas une très
bonne affaire pour l'agriculture
tout le sud des états unis devraient
également être concerné par ce genre
d'affaires par contre vous avez d'autres
endroits où globalement les selles
devrait devenir un peu plus humide alors
retenu quand même l'idée que vous avez
très peu pointillés
sur ce genre de gravats sur ce graphique
là ce qui signifie et dernier point
intéressant vous avez peut-être entendu
parler certains d'entre vous de la
sécheresse qui subit qui sévit
actuellement en australie et qui a fait
considérablement baisser les rendements
agricoles est bien la question se pose
quand vous voyez ce qui se passe ici
la question se pose de savoir si ça
n'est pas le début d'une évolution
tendancielle lourde qui va faire que les
rendements agricoles en australie son
parti a baissé de manière significative
parce qu'il y aura de moins en moins
d'eau dans les régions où ils cultivent
du b avec 6 si vous avez à l'agrément
comme je le disais tout à l'heure ce
genre de résultat pèse beaucoup plus des
questions que ça n'amène de réponse
encore une fois il faut pas prendre ça
comme une prévision ferme aussi ferme
que l'heure à laquelle commence un cours
demain ça c'est un truc sur lequel vous
pouvez raisonnablement considérer que
pour l'élite époque ça se passe
autrement est très faible
là ça pose des questions encore une fois
la réponse n'est qu'à la mesure de ce
qui a déjà été compris dans le
fonctionnement du système climatique et
de ces termes et dominant toujours au
même genre de question est-ce que
l'évolution récente de ce qui s'est
passé dans le système climatique et
quelque chose dans lequel on peut tenter
de déceler la trace de l'effet de serre
alors vous allez ici quelque chose qui
vous donne l'évolution relative du
nombre d'épisodes pluvieux intenses
alors je vais pas vous faire un entrepôt
sur ce que c'est que la définition d'un
épisode pluvieux intenses
en gros c'est un épisode dans lequel sur
une plage de temps donné la quantité
d'eau qui tombe dépasse d'un certain
pourcentage de la valeur moyenne de ce
qui tombe normalement quand il ya de la
pluie c'est comme ça que ça s'est fini
je puis chiffre exact est du reste et
vous voyez que c'est ces épisodes
pluvieux intenses a priori dans un
certain nombre d'endroits ils ont
significativement augmenté et pourrait
être tenté
parce que là aussi ça correspond à
quelque chose qui est attendu d'ivoire
déjà la trace du changement de climat
qui s'est opérée depuis 30 ans encore un
autre exemple vous avez ici l'évolution
degré d'humidité des sols avec un index
qui s'appelle l'index primaire et vous
voyez là aussi que la manière dont là
qu'est ce que je veux dire la sécheresse
des sols a évolué sur le courant du 20e
siècle
ça ressemble c'est pas exactement ça
mais ça ressemble à ce qui est attendu
pour le 21e siècle sur un certain nombre
d'endroits les sauces et sèche
vous reconnaissez ici c'est pas si tu as
même endroit c'est très clair quelque
part au milieu du continent américain il
ya des engrais moussa s'humidifie dans
la simulation je vous ai montré tout à
l'heure tout pas avant le milieu du
continent ça devait aussi s'humidifier
vous rappellerai aussi que quelque part
dans le nord de l'europe là ça devrait
se modifier or c'est ce qui a été
constaté sur le xxème siècle voilà bon
toujours c'est pareil ça pose une
question est ce que c'est nous est-ce
que c'est pas d'eau par contre il ya
deux cas de figure dans lequel la
question est très posé vous avez ici
quelque chose qui retrace le nombre
d'épisodes cévenols alors sais pas si
vous savez ce que c'est qu'un épisode
cévenol un épisode cévenol sait il ya
beaucoup de pluie qui tombe sur les
cévennes nous saluons les cévennes non
non c'est pas vrai je vous jure
tout fout le camp les cévennes ce sont
des montagnes qui sont situées sur le
sud du massif central et au nord de
montpellier et qui ont la particularité
en général en septembre à un moment où
la méditerranée est encore relativement
chaude et où les terres ont commencé à
se refroidir d'être l'objet d'épisodes
pluvieux intenses on appelle les
épisodes cévenols
alors c'est un orage qui va durer un
certain temps puis il ya plein de flotte
qui tombe dans le fond des vallées
nîmes est inondée le ministre de
l'environnement chose des grandes
puissances et va expliquer aux gens que
ce qui leur arrive
c'est pas drôle voilà c'est ça un
épisode cévenol alors question est ce
que bernard a de plus en plus bas la
réponse non vous avez ici le nombre
d'épisodes cévenols depuis 1960 enfin
1958 très exactement
vous voyez qu'il ya pas de tendance
marquée à la hausse ou à la baisse par
contre une chose qui est absolument
certaine c'est qu'il ya une tendance à
la hausse extrêmement marqué
nombre d'habitations et de bâtiments
inondés il se trouve que l'urbanisation
en france c'est tout j'ai fait le long
des cours d'eau qui historiquement ont
servi de premières balles deux premières
voies de communication donc une ville
comme vous le savez c'est toujours
traversée par un fleuve ou une rivière
c'est jamais très loin de l'eau c'est
vrai aussi pour les villes qui sont en
aval des cévennes
alors dans les temps anciens on élite
est quand même de construire en rade la
rivière et puis la pression foncière et
dans et de plus de plus de gens roulent
en faire construire juste en bord de
rivière quelquefois c'est même les
pompiers qui font ça et bien vous avez
de plus en plus de bâtiments au bord du
lit de la rivière et quentin la guerre
déborde pas plus fort qu'avant
nécessairement il ya plus en plus de
trucs qui sont inondées
là vous est typiquement dans un cas de
figure dans lequel l'augmentation des
dégâts n'a pas de signification sur la
variation de la cause je vais vous
donner un autre exemple d'ingénierie
quand je parlerai des ouragans
mais il ya un autre exemple tout à fait
non exactement exactement identique en
ce qui concerne quand on va maintenant
commencer à rentrer dans des choses qui
sont un tout petit peu plus difficile à
évaluer
qui est ce qu'il va se passer en ce qui
concerne l'avenir de la végétation
vous avez ici sur la carte en haut à
droite
la répartition sur la planète de ce
qu'on appelle les biomes c'est à dire
les grands titres dominante végétation
par zone de résidence donc vous voyez
par exemple que ici vous avez de la
forêt tropicale d'afrique équatoriale
également et puis pour ce qu'il en reste
en indonésie et en papouasie de meunier
ici vous allez plutôt de la savane de
même que en afrique tropicale etc il ya
des envois vous avez des déserts des
envois vous avez des forêts tempérées
et des endroits où ils avaient des
forêts boréales un peu plus haut puis
des envois vous avez de la savane ou la
toundra lattuga pardon pas de salle
c'était vraiment la même latitude
ça c'est la répartition actuelle ce
carte là vous ben de manière très
schématique ceux qui gouvernent à la
possibilité d'avoir un écosystème donné
à un endroit de la planète
vous voyez elle est en fait vous avez
ici en ordonner la température moyenne
annuelle de la zone en question et en
abscisse les précipitations annuelles
moyennes de la zone en question et vous
voyez que par exemple quand il ya très
peu de précipitations quelle que soit la
température vous allez trouver les
déserts et de solidaires
quand vous avez un petit peu plus de
précipitations quelle que soit la
température
c'est pour ça que j'ai confondu les deux
tout à l'heure selon la dre vous êtes
vous allée de la toundra où vous allez
de la savane mais enfin en gros vous
avez des endroits où ils peuvent pas
grand chose
puis vous allez avoir des forêts puis
vous allez avoir des forêts humides
alors également les forêts humides il
faut qu'il pleuve plus que dans les
forêts sèches ce que veut yeux sur cette
répartition des écosystèmes par grandes
zones climatiques
c'est que quand vous changez les
précipitations ou quand vous changez de
plage de précipitations vous changez
d'écosystèmes en place beaucoup plus
vite que quand vous changez la
température moyenne annuelle
en d'autres termes ce qui va faire qu'un
écosystème va rester prospère ou pas ça
va beaucoup plus être les variations de
précipitations que les variations de la
température annuelle moyenne annuelle
moyenne est l'une des raisons pour
lesquelles on ne voit pas les dangers
liés au changement climatique
quand on en parle dans la grande presse
c'est que la grande presse se focalise
sur les températures je suis à peu près
sûr que vous n'avez quasiment jamais vu
de variation de précipitations en
être de pluie dans un article de la
grande presse en ce qui concerne le
changement climatique
or c'est essentiellement les variations
des précipitations qui vont faire qu'il
va y avoir des dégâts ou pas de dégâts
la température va jouer aussi
mais c'est le couple on va dire le
couple précipitations température qui
fait que des dégâts ou pas de dégâts je
vais vous donner un exemple très
nationale imaginons que vous ayez un
viticulteur dans votre famille
et bien si la température est printemps
se radoucit dans un printemps sec qui
s'en fiche
si ça se radoucit dans un printemps
humide ils s'en fichent pas du tout
parce qu'il voit paris voit apparaître
des taux de parasites la différence
entre les deux c'est pas la température
c'est les précipitations c'est
exactement pareil en ce qui concerne les
forêts imaginons que la moyenne des
températures en france rex et reste
exactement ce qu'elle est et que les
précipitations père de 25 ou 30 % en
moyenne
vous avez pas besoin de toucher aux
températures pour faire disparaître
l'essentiel des forêts donc les
précipitations
c'est un élément qui va gouverner
l'évolution de zones favorables pour les
écosystèmes beaucoup plus que les
températures cette chance c'est
justement le paramètre sur lequel la
visibilité et modèle est moins bonne que
en ce qui concerne les températures
température c'est plus robustes comme
conclusion les précipitations ce plus
difficile parce que comme je vous le
disais la dernière fois les
précipitations dépendent essentiellement
de processus de petite échelle
typiquement les nuages qui ne sont pas
pris en compte de manière explicite dans
les modèles qui sont utilisées donc
d'avoir des conclusions robuste et
fiable avec un très faible écart type en
ce qui concerne les précipitations est
quelque chose qui est bien plus
difficile que en ce qui concerne les
températures
alors une fois que je vous ai donné
toutes ces précautions d'usagé
je peux quand même vous donner quelques
exemples de chose qui pourrait arriver
on va prendre un premier exemple ici
vous avez une simulation qui ont été
réalisés par l'inra c'est à dire le
laboratoire de recherche publique qui
est chargé de l'agronomie dans notre
pays vous avez deux cartes
la première vous donne la distribution
dû être
en france aujourd'hui vous avez donc
quelque chose qui est gradué du bleu au
rouge et qui est la probabilité
d'occurrence pour éviter de rencontrer
un être
on va dire dans les forêts du coin voilà
pas si vous marchez des yeux bandés un
lendemain de fête
voilà donc en bleu ça correspond à la
distribution à l'importance relative du
être dans ce que vous allez voir ce que
vous allez rencontrer alors ce que ça
dit en gros cette carte c'est que sur
les postures du bassin méditerranéen à
la probabilité 12 a rencontré dur sauf
si vous avez un jardin d'hiver est
quelqu'un qui en a fait un bond de sai
mais sinon c'est nul et que plus vous
allez du sud ouest vers l'est et plus la
probabilité de rencontrer été levée en
gruissan particulièrement bien là y sent
particulièrement bien en asie centrale
ils sont encore à peu près bien encore
et puis plus vous allez vers l'ouest et
moi il sent bien même le plus encore en
trouver ici vous avez la distribution dû
être dans un climat qui a été modifié
avec le scénario des missions le plus
bas de la fourchette donc le scénario
émission constante ou quasi constante et
bien vous voyez que dans l'essentiel du
pays l'affaiblissement des façades
maritimes du pays
il n'est plus possible de trouver dû
être il est plus possible non plus d'en
trouver dans le couloir rhodanien dans
la bretagne et dans le nord vous avez
encore la possibilité d'en trouver des
pas de clous et vous avez un réservoir
voilà il en reste en montagne ici et
puis dans les vosges et du jura et puis
ailleurs mondorfois y en a plus
énormément
il fait bien voir que dans ce genre de
simulation c'est malheureusement la
partie blanche qui est la plus robuste
c'est à dire que là vous êtes
complètement sortis des paramètres
climatiques nécessaires à la vie du
hêtre ou il est raisonnablement sûr
qu'il y en aura plus ailleurs vous n'en
savez rien parce que ce genre de
simulation ne prend pas en compte
l'apparition éventuelle de ravageurs la
compétition entre espèces les incendies
ou le fait que les gens iront tout coupé
parce que rapide pétrole je vous le
rappelle ce que je vous ai déjà dit au
moment du cours sur le charbon c'est le
charbon qu'à sauver les forêts
françaises
on était en train de couple tout jouer à
dix
pour alimenter les forges et le charbon
est apparu et a fait qu' on n'est pas
allé jusqu'au bout de la déforestation
donc ce genre d'évolution ça ne tient
que pour autant que les hypothèses que
vous faites soient raisonnables et en
particulier ce que je vous dis ce que je
viens de vous dire c'est que il ya des
tas de trucs qui en général le fond
plutôt que ça pourrait être pire que
mieux ne sont pas pris en compte dans ce
sens de simulation avec les mêmes
réserves
vous avez ici une autre simulation qui
porte sur l'air de distribution du sapin
voilà donc vous avez aujourd'hui des
sapins dans les massifs montagneux
essentiellement en 2100 avec un climat
qui serait modifiée par le scénario des
missions le plus bas encore une fois
donc là il n'est pas question d'un
scénario charbon e 1 c'est vraiment le
scénario des missions le plus bas est
bien embrouillée le sapin a disparu de
quasiment partout je retrouvais encore
un peu dans le massif central il a
disparu de quasiment partout sauf une
partie des alpes les alpes du nord et
une petite partie du jura voilà cette
affaire avec les mêmes réserves que ce
que je vous disais tout à l'heure
parce que si d'ici à 2100 vous avez cinq
étés 2003 ou un peu pire l'un derrière
l'autre
vous pouvez très bien avoir quelque
chose qui je vous rappelle que l'homme
par exemple est un art qui a disparu les
forêts françaises
personne ne sait si c'est le
réchauffement climatique mais c'est
quelque chose qui est allé assez vite
aux quinze jours un parasite qui est
apparue une maladie et les hommes ont
été éradiqués de france encore une fois
ce genre de processus n'est pas prise en
compte dans ce genre de simulation
je vais vous donner un autre exemple de
processus qui s'est déroulé il ya pas
longtemps dans notre pays
vous avez une maladie des végétaux qui
s'appelle l'oïdium qui est un petit
champignon qui apparaît sur les feuilles
et qui a tendance à les habous criant ça
empêche les feuilles de bien se
développer
quand ce parasite apparaît sur un arbre
qui a déjà formé ses feuilles
ça lui bouffe un peu les failles
existantes mais ça n'empêche pas de
vivre comme ce parasite appareils sur
les bourgeons parce que la température a
été plus que lente l'hiver et donc il a
pu se développer plus tôt eh bien ça
empêche considérablement plus les
feuilles de
p et si ça apparaît plusieurs années
successives labeaume heures parce qu'il
est incapable de reconstituer ses
réserves
voilà vous avez typiquement un exemple
dans lequel vous avez une espèce des
faits transistors 1
c'est à dire que un petit effet sur une
petite bête en l'occurrence qui ne fait
que décaler de 1 ou 2 mois la date à
laquelle la petite bête commence à
produire ses conséquences ça peut avoir
des grès résultats et causé la
disparition d'une espèce qui avait là un
point de faiblesse c'était son talon
d'achille
ce genre de processus ça ça rentre
typiquement dans la dernière ligne rouge
que je vous avais montré sur le
transparent introductif c'est à dire ces
deux processus sur lesquels s'il doit y
avoir une mauvaise surprise
on le saura quand la mauvaise surprise
sera là c'est très difficile de
modéliser à l'avance ce genre de choses
ce qu'on peut quand même dire en termes
de conclusion on va dire un peu global
c'est que en ce qui concerne les petites
bêtes dont je viens de vous parler de
manière abondante en ce qui concerne les
arbres vous avez quand même une
conclusion générale qui est que plus
vous chauffer le bouillon de culture est
en général but elle se porte
vous avez ici un diagramme qui
représente de manière extrêmement
schématique évidemment la quantité de
micro organismes pathogènes que vous
avez donc la biodiversité des agents
pathogènes
parce que la biodiversité ça existe
aussi chez eux des agents pathogènes que
vous allez trouver en fonction de votre
distance à l'équateur d'envoyer quand
vous êtes au pôle nord au sud
des agents pathogènes y en a pas
énormément et puis plus vous rapprocher
de l'équateur et plus vous allez en
trouver quand vous voyez ce genre de
distribution évidemment une des
conclusions que vous êtes tentés d'en
tirer c'est que dans un climat qui
globalement se réchauffe les êtres qui
vivent quelque part qu'il s'agisse de
plantes d'animaux ou d'hommes vont être
exposés à un nombre croissant d'agents
pathogènes
c'est quelque chose qu'on a envie de
penser alors en l'espèce
ça va être vrai en particulier pour les
moyennes latitudes
ça ne suffit pas pour autant à dire que
l'on va plus ou moins mourir parce que
pour dire ça il faut également être
capable de donner des conclusions sur la
manière dont le système de soins va
s'adapter à cette nouvelle donne je vous
rappelle qu'en ce qui concerne le
paludisme qui est une maladie dont on
entend souvent parler dans le cadre d'un
relèvement des températures et qui est
aujourd'hui est une des premières causes
de mortalité à la surface de la planète
il y en a eu en france et il a été
éradiquée parce que on a mis du ddt dans
les marécages donc le paludisme est
quelque chose qui a déjà eu lieu dans
notre pays sans réchauffement climatique
et c'était là c'est à la frontière entre
la manière dont vont évoluer les
micro-organismes et la manière dont va
évoluer la société humaine que vous
allez trouver des dégâts ou l'absence de
dégâts quelques exemples en ce qui
concerne les maladies
et puis il y en a plein d'autres premier
exemple vous avez ici le nombre de cas
de salmonelloses la salmonellose est une
infection digestive qui peut provoquer
des choses désagréables c'est rare qu'on
en meure de manière importante
mais vous avez pardon non c'est pas une
maladie qui fait énormément de morts à
la surface de la planète
vous en avez d'autres qui font des morts
mais celle là celle là elle est
intéressante parce que vous avez ici une
étude qui a été faite
je rentre en aura d'autres après qu'ils
sont plus des adverbes un certain qu'ils
aient une étude qui a été faite en
nouvelle zélande et on a regardé la
prévalence de cette maladie en fonction
de la température moyenne et vous voyez
que quand la température moyenne
augmente avec une dispersion qui
augmente vous avez quand même le nombre
de cas moyens qui a tendance à augmenter
cette étude a en fait été répétée dans
d'autres pays et on a trouvé des
conclusions à peu près identique donc en
veut
c'est une infection pour laquelle quand
vous augmenter la température ambiante
le nombre de gens infectés a globalement
tendance à croître avec encore une fois
une dispersion qui augmente
manière significative ici vous avez une
courbe très simple sur laquelle je vais
disserter très longtemps parce que elle
concerne un exemple particulier de ce
qu'on appelle les maladies à vecteur
alors les maladies à vecteur sont des
maladies dans lesquelles ça n'est pas
vous n'êtes comment dire l'agent
pathogène vous ai transmis par un être
vivant intermédiaire qu'on appelle un
vecteur une tique un moustique une puce
ça peut être un rat ça peut être la
sangsue peut-être je sais pas enfin bon
bref
et c'est souvent des insectes ou des
êtres vivants qui vont avoir la
possibilité par leur piqûre ou leur
morsure d'entrer directement en contact
avec votre sang c'est le cas de tous les
insectes suceurs les puces les
moustiques etc
justin a jauni par passion que les
moustiques nous en avait des dizaines ou
des centaines d'espèces roland plus et
sans peine que des dizaines et toutes
les espèces de moustiques ne sont pas
adaptés aux mêmes des écosystèmes en ce
qui concerne certaines maladies
redoutable vous avez certaines espèces
de moustiques qui peuvent la transmettre
d'autres espèces de moustiques qui ne
peuvent pas par exemple vous avez des
longévités dans les espèces de
moustiques qui peuvent être différents
d'une espèce à l'autre et vous avez des
parasites qui ont des durées
d'incubation minimale dans le système
digestif du moustique qui peuvent varier
ben si le moustique il a une vie
aérienne qui est inférieur la durée
minimale d'incubation du parasite
il n'est pas capable de transmettre le
parasite si il a une longévité dans sa
partie aérienne puisque avec le
moustique aussi une partie aquatique
sous forme de larves dans sa partie
aérienne il a une longévité qui est trop
qui est suffisante pour que le parasite
puisse se développer dans son tube
digestif et bien à ce moment c'est
potentiellement un vecteur infectant
donc vous avez c'est compliqué cette
affaire-là il suffit pas de dire on va y
avoir plus de moustiques donc on va
avoir des maladies ça marche pas comme
ça
il faut regarder comment se comporte le
vecteur face à une modification des
conditions climatiques global est
toujours prendre l'exemple des
moustiques
selon qui pleut plus ou qu'il pleut
moins et bien le moustique il a trouvé
ça plutôt plus sympathique moins
sympathique 1
le moustique il a besoin de marbella
besoin d'eau stagnante pour pouvoir se
développer
alors des fois le fait qu'ils peuvent
plus c'est une bonne affaire des fois le
fait qu'ils peuvent croire est une bonne
affaire parce que ça va introduire des
poches d'eau stagnante dans les condos
dont il sait retenir l'idée que vous
avez que vous avez très difficilement
les moyens à partir d'une évolution qui
est essentiellement caractérisé par des
paramètres très macro et une vision très
macron sur la température et les
précipitations
c'est très difficile de commencer à
faire des calculs qui est un sens sur le
nombre de gens qui vont mourir du
paludisme de la dengue de la fièvre
jaune ou la fièvre de la vallée du rift
c'est extrêmement difficile et ça n'a
pas beaucoup de sens qu'il est possible
de dire c'est pour un certain nombre de
ces maladies il va y avoir une pression
à la hausse
probablement que le changement
climatique va également accélérer un
autre processus qui a toujours été à
l'origine d'épidémies redoutable qui est
la mutation des virus par exemple des
virus de la grippe sans changement
climatique cela étant vous avez un
certain nombre de virologues qui vous
expliquent que la grippe aviaire
un jour elle sera transmissible d'homme
à homme bah suffit d'attendre la bête va
buter muté buts et but et puis un jour
elle trouvera l'habitation adapté et
elle sera transmissible d'homme à homme
je vous rappelle encore une fois que la
grippe espagnole a tué plus de monde que
la guerre 14 18 ans donc la grippe
espagnole qui a eu lieu en 1970 18 19
dans ces eaux-là a tué plus de monde
elle a tué quasiment 20 millions de
personnes que la guerre de 14 18 donc
encore une fois dans un monde qui est
multi déterminez vous voir isolé
une seule variation aura un seul
paramètre qui est en train de varier en
dix ans ce milieu à porter l'entière
responsabilité du fait que le nombre de
morts de la dengue va être multiplié par
dix
c'est quelque chose qui n'aurait pas
beaucoup de sens parce que dans le
siècle que nous allons vivre des tas de
choses ont changé
le fait que le climat change est plutôt
globalement une mauvaise affaire pour
les maladies fois qu'on a dit ça on a à
peu près tout dit alors regardez
maintenant un exemple un peu plus micro
un peu plus à dire un peu mieux
documenter sur la corrélation observée
entre à paramètres climatiques à grande
échelle et des conséquences sanitaires
vous avez ici sur ce graphique les
anomalies de température du pacifique
est par rapport à sa valeur normale qui
est le 0 sur la courbe donc vous voyez
que le pacifique est il a de temps en
temps envie d'être un peu plus chaud que
la normale celle épique que vous
observez ici alors est ce que quelqu'un
dans cette salle c'est ce que ces cas
pacifique est ce qui est un peu plus
chaud que la normale
si vous le savez tous sauf que vous sauf
que vous n'avez pas pris comme ça ça
s'appelle el niño quand vous êtes en
condition elle mignot et bien d'autres
avec une grande oscillations du système
climatique planétaire
eh bien vous vous mettez à avoir le
pacifique est qui est plus chaud que la
normale ce qui déplace les autres de
mousson ce qui fait des incendies en
californie et des tas d'autres choses de
ce type là est bien quand vous êtes à
condition elle mignot vous avez tendance
à avoir une prévalence du choléra au
bangladesh qui augmente ça s'explique de
manière parfaitement normal vous allez
augmenter de précipitations sur la
partie est du pacifique
il se trouve que le bangladesh est
plutôt près de la partie est du
pacifique
vous allez également légèrement dilater
l'autre surface parce qu'il fait un peu
plus chaud que d'habitude 1 et tout ça
est parfaitement favorable au
développement du germe qui est
responsable du choléra
vibrion du choléra qui aime bien les
eaux saumâtres qui sont en bord de mer
et donc vous avez une augmentation des
épidémies de choléra au bangladesh
ça c'est un cas qui est documenté ex
post
encore une fois bien malin qui peut
faire des calculs qui pourraient
documenté etc santé ce qui va se passer
demain donc quand vous voyez pas c'est
un calcul dans lequel on vous explique
que la fièvre jaune va faire 4 88
millions de morts en 2025
méfiez-vous ça veut pas dire que ce soit
impossible
ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui il n'existe
pas de raisonnement étayé qui permettent
de bornes et de manière aussi fine les
conséquences sanitaires possibles du
changement climatique et puis encore une
fois ça va tout ça va dépendre de
l'endroit où ça arrive et des moyens de
prévention qu'ils seront disponibles
on va maintenant passer à une autre
conséquence du changement climatique qui
est l'élévation du niveau de la mer
alors l'élévation du niveau de la mer
c'est quelque chose qu'on pourrait
penser comme étant très simple équipe
est partie est très simple et en fait
pour partie c'est assez compliqué vous
vous souvenez que l'océan est une grande
baignoire l'océan ne va pas jusqu'au
centre de la terre puis de l'autre côté
donc le second est une grande baignoire
quand vous chauffer l'eau dans une
baignoire l'eau chauffée se dilatant une
chose à laquelle on peut raisonnablement
s'attendre c'est que le niveau de l'eau
monte
y a pas que ça dans ce qui va contribuer
à la hausse du niveau de l'océan une
deuxième chose qui va contribuer à cette
hausse
c'est que vous avez un certain nombre de
glaçon posé sur la terre ferme des
petits glaçons la mer de glace le
glacier des bossons le glacier blanc et
c'est des gros bras sont le groenland et
l'antarctique
ces glaçons s'il fonde ils vont bien
évidemment alimenté l'océan en
ruisselant
et ça va là aussi faire monter le niveau
de la mer la dilatation de l'eau à
l'échelle des 21e siècle est quelque
chose qui va être beaucoup plus
significatif que l'eau de fonte des
glaciers des
une attitude retenez que si on fait
fondre tous les glaciers des moyennes
latitudes donc plus de mer de glace plus
de glacier des bossons le mont-blanc
perche et plus combien lui tout dit m
plus de glaciers dans les angles plus et
ses fins du kilimandjaro le seller
mondial peu à peu prend à peu près 30 cm
c'est l'ordre de grandeur qu'il faut
avoir en tête après on va s'intéresser
au cas de colère alors les calottes
polaires
on en a souvent l'idée de quelque chose
de pas épais pour deux raisons d'abord
parce que quand on vous parle des glaces
polaires ou parle beaucoup plus souvent
de la banquise que la calotte polaire la
banquise c'est tout plein air et en os
et la deuxième raison pour laquelle ont
souvent on s'imagine que c'est tout plat
c'est que la majeure partie des temps
près du temps pardon vous voyez le
groenland sur une carte
1 voilà c'est un truc vieux et donc
c'est aussi plat que la mère qui
l'entourent en fait une calotte polaire
ça fait plusieurs kilomètres d'épaisseur
et c'est exactement comme pour le mont
blanc entre la température en bas et la
température en haut on soit l'été ou
l'hiver c'est pas exactement la même
température donc dans un climat qui
globalement se réchauffe il va y avoir
des évolutions contrastées entre le haut
et le bas de la carte le bas de la
calotte va être soumis de plus en plus
souvent à des températures positives et
donc il va se mettre à fondre en
particulier pour le groenland
mais dans le même temps je vous ai
montré la dernière fois qu'on allait
avoir dans un climat qui se réchauffe un
cycle de l'eau qui s'intensifie plus de
l'irak aurait donc plus de qui précipite
et en particulier plus de qui va se
mettre à précipiter sur le sol mais de
la calotte mal le températures annuelles
moyennes sont plutôt négatives et ça
bien évidemment ça va accroître la
quantité 2 stocké sous forme solide au
sommet de la calotte donc vous allez
vous retrouver avec une cale est qui va
perdre de la masse ici et au moins dans
un premier temps gagner de la masse ici
et il est bien évident que la résultante
de l'océan c'est qu'on va retrouver dans
notre grande baignoire ce qui a fondu
ici non ce qui s'est accumulée l'a donc
le bilan nasse du groenland vous donne
le signe de la contribution de ces deux
évolutions contrat
et à l'élévation du niveau de la mer et
vous voyez que ça n'a rien d'une
orthodoxe que dans un monde qui se
réchauffe vous ayez les calottes
glaciaires qui transitoirement gagne de
la masse ça n'a rien d'une orthodoxie
c'est quelque chose qui est parfaitement
possible alors en fait on valoir que
s'est différencié et que en ce qui
concerne le groenland
maintenant on est plus dans gain de
masse par contre on est toujours
probablement ce qui concerne
l'antarctique enfin vous avez un dernier
réflexe du réchauffement sur la glace
qui lui n'a pas d'effet direct sur le
niveau bleu parce que archimède a dit
que c'était comme ça qui est la fonte de
la banquise
à partir du moment où vous faites fondre
à glaçons qui est déjà en train de
flotter dans l'eau
bah ma foi ça ne change pas le niveau de
l'eau normalement au niveau d'étude
auquel vous êtes devriez vous souvenir
de ça par contre ça va avoir un effet
indirect
ça va avoir un effet indirect parce que
si vous faites fondre cette banquise
comme je vous le disais tout à l'heure
vous allez augmenter la quantité
d'énergie solaire qui est absorbé par
l'océan donc par la surface qui entoure
la calotte groenlandaise et donc vous
allez augmenter la température régional
près de la calotte et donc accélérer le
processus de fonte sur la partie basse
donc la fonte de la banquise n'a pas
d'effet direct sur le niveau de l'océan
par contre par un coup de billard à de
grandes ça a un effet indirect
parce que ça augmente la température
locale près de la calotte groenlandaise
regardez un peu comment toutes ces
choses ont évolué sur les dernières
décennies vous avez ici l'extension de
la banquise à la fin de l'été arctique
en hiver
la bâtisse couvre la totalité de l'océan
arctique et même bien au delà
par contre en été elles régressent et
elle ne couvraient plus qu'une partie de
l'océan arctique
mais pour le moment il y en a toujours
sur une partie de l'océan arctique
le minima ou le mini même à la fin de
l'été arctique est représenté sur cette
courbe où vous voyez qu'il ya une très
nette tendance à la baisse
l'extension à la fin de l'été de la
bêtise puisque dans les années 80 ça
couvrait entre 7 et 8 millions de
kilomètres carrés nous sommes
actuellement plutôt aux alentours de 5 à
6 et en fait c'est un peu tôt pour
savoir si c'est un point singulier mais
il se trouve qu'en 2007
on est descendu entre 3 et 4 millions de
kilomètres carrés en ce qui concerne
l'extension de la banquise à la fin de
l'été si on est déjà dans un processus
d'accélération
vous voyez qu'il faut revoir une partie
des simulations dont je viens de vous
parler à la route parce que le processus
d'amplification près du pôle nord va
s'accélérer il va aller plus vite que ce
qui était contenue aujourd'hui dans les
simulations et bien évidemment par
ricochet ça va amplifier les
conséquences pour le système climatique
glad ce que je vous ai raconté tout à
l'heure sur la fonte du groenland et j'y
reviendrai c'est que la valeur de
l'immobilier à noirmoutier va
partiellement dépendre de la vitesse à
laquelle le groenland à fondre c'est
quelque chose qu'on a du mal à
comprendre quand on n'y pense pas une
fois qu'on y pense ça paraît absolument
évident je vous parlais tout à l'heure
du bilan de masse du grand n langues
le voici le graphique de gauche
un graphique assez compliqué vous donne
justement le bilan de masse du groenland
depuis 1960
alors il s'interprète de la manière
suivante ce graphique vous avez un
certain nombre de chercheurs de par le
monde qui ont regardé comment évoluer la
masse du groenland donc ce que je vous
disais tout à l'heure ce qui rentre mois
ce qui sort ou dans l'autre sens comme
vous voulez et bien évidemment comme ça
découle de calcul et pas d'une
métrologie absolument exact il n'ya pas
l' expert géomètre qui passe et qui
mesure tous partout dans tous les sens
pour avoir le volume exact de glace sur
pied ya une bande erreur au calcul qui
sont faits j'ai pas les jeux quand lemon
et peu importe vous avez ici par exemple
6h à la monsieur h de 1960 à 1990 ils
considèrent que le bilan menace du
groenland était allé
gare annuel quand vous au taz est russe
et que nissan ne gagnent nissan perd
donc monsieur âge considère que 260 à
1990 l'accumulation sur la partie
c'était plutôt un peu supérieur à la
fonte sur la partie basse est bien
évidemment une part d'erreur dont qui
chasseront c'était déjà en rappeur et si
ça se trouve ça s'accumule de plus qu'il
ne le pensait et puis un certain nombre
d'autres personnes qui sont mis à faire
des évaluations de monsieur z
il a fait entre 90 et 2003 monsieur t il
à fait dans les années 90 puis il a
refait dans les années début des années
2000 le suaire il a fait à ce moment là
il a fait ce moment là etc
il vaudrait mieux que si vous prenez une
courbe de tendance pour toutes les
personnes qui ont fait ce genre
d'exercice vous avez quelque chose qui
est une très nette plongée c'est à dire
que avec le temps on considère que le
bilan de masse du groenland est de plus
en plus une perte nette est de plus en
plus importante et qui va en
s'accélérant conduite en car que le
processus est et non linéaire ou la
perte et la perte est fortement convexe
comme vous voulez ce graphique quand
vous le montrer aux glaciologues du
laboratoire des sciences du climat et de
l'environnement à sa claire ils vous
disent ah mon dieu
tout ça est déjà dépassé ça va encore
beaucoup plus vite que ça l'un d'eux
processus qui en particulier est en
train de prendre semble-t-il une
importance qu'ils n'avaient pas été
soupçonné jusqu'à maintenant et
l'affirmation de ce qu'on appelle du
moulin quand je sais pas si vous savez
ce que c'est les boules un ces deux
lieux qui font en surface et qui va par
des trous dans la calotte glaciaire
allait tomber jusqu'au fonte de la
calotte et ça va créer un petit matelas
fluide sur lequel la calotte parce qu'il
va se remettre de l'eau
entre le rocher est là et la langue de
glace et comme le groenland et en pente
en tout cas près de la mer eh bien ça va
accélérer le glissement de la calotte
vers l'eau donc bien évidemment ça va
encore plus vite que la fonte
si au lieu de prendre le temps de faire
fondre la glace vous prenez la glace et
vous n'aurez qu'un iceberg vous
débarrassez encore plus vite la calotte
de sa glace donc ce processus là
vraisemblablement est en train
d'accélérer de manière significative la
perte de glace du groenland sur le
graphique de droite vous avez les
simulations qui étaient fournis en 2001
en ce qui concerne la quantité
raul et négation du niveau de l'océan
qu'on pouvait la voir en l'an 3000
c'est ça qui est intéressant est là en
cm en truction de la température
exactement du supplément de température
moyenne que vous aurez au dessus du
griot de langue en l'an 3000 monde aussi
d'ici à l'an 3000
on gagne 3 degrés au dessus du groenland
alors le droit de lang contribuera à la
hausse du niveau de la mer pourra mettre
sur cette période
si on gagne 5 degrés il y contribuer a
pour 3 m et si on gagne degré ils font
en quasi totalité puisque si le
groenland fond en totalité ses 6 7 6 à 7
m 2 que vous avez en plus dans le niveau
des océans
aujourd'hui ce que vise le glaciologue
c'est ce que bella elles ont tendance à
croître beaucoup plus vite
c'est à dire que le groenland pourrait
fournir jusqu'à un mètre d'élévation du
niveau de la mer dans le courant du
siècle qui a commencé à cause de
processus dont je viens de vous parler
de manière
j'espère un peu détaillé soit dit en
passant
8 degrés au dessus du groenland dans un
millénaire il suffit pour ça que la
température planétaire près de 2 à 3
degrés dans le siècle qui commence parce
que près du pôle nord ce sera amplifié
et en l'an 3000
ça sera plus qu'en l'an 2100 je vous ai
montré la dernière fois que c'était pas
réversible cette affaire donc ce qui
sait retenir c'est que vous avez une
inconnue absolument majeur en ce qui
concerne l'évolution du groenland à
l'échelle du siècle
au delà qui sait qu'aujourd'hui les
projections sur l'élévation du niveau de
l'océan à l'échelle du siècle on
considère qu' elles sont de plus en plus
incertaine mais dans le mauvais sens du
terme c'est à dire que ça pourra être
significativement plus que l'idée qu'on
s'en fait jusqu'à maintenant vous avez
une autre calotte sur laquelle vous avez
exactement le même genre
d'interrogations qui est la calotte
antarctique
vous avez ici une image exactement une
cartographie de l'antarctique avec une
indication très particulière superposés
sur cette tarte de l'antarctique car je
vous rappelle que l'antarctique ça fait
aussi quelques kilomètres d'épaisseur
qui hélas variations d'altitude qui a
été enregistrée en ce qui concerne le
sommet de la calotte alors là c'est sur
une période très courte danser sur une
décennie
pourquoi est-ce que c'est sur une
période très courte parce que c'est des
mesures satellite
les satellites c'est depuis les années
70 et puis dans les premières dans la
dans la première partie de la vie des
satellites le premier truc qui venait à
l'esprit des gens ce n'est pas d'en
lancer pour les mesurer l'épaisseur du
pôle sud en général ils ont fait autre
chose avant et ici vous avez donc un
satellite qui a été lancée exprès pour
ça c'est à dire qu'il a il fait
d'altimétrie en d'arrière-garde
l'attitude de ce qu'on observe sur terre
l'évolution de l'altitude de la calotte
vous donne évidemment le sens où de
l'accumulation ou au contraire de la
perte de glace si l'altitude a plutôt
tendance à monter pour augmenter
l'attitude du sommet ça veut dire un de
l'accueillir de la glace qui
s'accumulent et donc que vous êtes
plutôt un bilan est positif
par contre vous avez une partie de la
calotte qu'on appelle la calotte
occidentales on vous voyez que vous avez
une perte d'altitude
c'est ce qui est marqué à côté là du
petit
petit des petits triangles et enfin de
ce petit triangle est là donc c'est un
endroit où vraisemblablement la galette
est en train de perdre de la glace se
trouve que l'athlète qui est pesée qui
est posé sur cette partie de
l'antarctique
elle repose sur un socle très chaud qui
est sous marins donc la calotte est
posée sur un socle qui est sous le
niveau de la mer et ce socle rechute
également en compte pour partie et vous
avez ici des grandes langue de glace
flottante dans la mer deux médailles de
la mer de ross qui sait le dark bouton
et qui empêche le la partie principale
de la calotte de fiche le camp d'ados
mais vous avez aussi un comment dire une
formation physique qui est à risque
parce que si la mère se réchauffe
ça va attaquer la langue de glace qui
c'est à bart bouton puisqu'elle soit sur
l'eau si jamais ces arcs boutants
commence à s'en aller
ça veut dire que la calotte qui est
posée sur le socle rocheux va avoir
tendance à glisser plus rapidement vers
la mer et elle sera aidée en cela par le
fait que la mère va lui lécher les pieds
puisque le socle rocheux et sous marins
sous le niveau de la mer comme je vous
le disais là vous avez un risque de ce
que les anglo-saxons appellent la
désintégration de la calotte occidentale
de l'antarctique mal mal impossible à
évaluer
donc personne ne sait si c'est pour le
siècle qui vient dans deux siècles dans
trois siècles ou etc
par contre de plus en plus de physiciens
considère qu'on a là affaire à un risque
qui est très sérieux à l'échelle de
quelques siècles cette masse de glace là
c'est également six mètres dos en plus
pour le niveau de l'océan si elle venait
à se retrouver dans l'eau donc vous
voyez quelle échelle du ou de quelques
siècles va un facteur de risque qui
porte sur 10 à 12 mètres d'élévation du
niveau des mers impossible abordé de
manière rationnelle et ayez en disant je
vous garantis qu'à pas plus que temps ou
au contraire vous garantit qu attend au
minimum qui dit ya un grand facteur de
risque dit évidemment que on serait bien
inspiré de s'en occuper rapidement ce
graphique
vous donne l'élévation du niveau de
l'océan compte tenu du groenland à
l'échelle et l'antarctique à l'échelle
du siècle
donc en gros ce que dit ce graphique
c'est que s'il n'ya pas le groenland et
si ya pas l'antarctique
la dilatation du niveau de l'eau plus la
fonte des glaciers des moyennes
latitudes à un mur ces quelques dizaines
de centimètres d'élévation que nous
risquons mais comme je le disais tout à
l'heure il ya l'inconnue du groenland
est là qu on récitait hervé le treut
l'idée que vous pouvez retenir de ce
graphique c'est que à l'échelle du
siècle c'est au moins quelques dizaines
de centimètres et au dessus on sait
faire voilà c'est quelque chose qui
correspond assez bien à mon avis on
résumer que vous pouvez garder de cette
affaire alors que vous libérer pour
l'intercours retenez cette idée qui est
que les dégâts liés à l'augmentation du
niveau des océans se matérialiseront par
crise souvent on a l'idée naïve que
quand le niveau de la mer monde c'est
comme quand la barre et bien vous lécher
les pieds en bretagne et on voit le truc
venir à la vengeance
et puis dès qu'on trouvera toute froide
ou que l'écran viennent vous chatouiller
les orteils crocs pour monter d'un mètre
le problème est réglé sauf que dans la
vraie vie c'est pas comme ça que leur
espace et dans la vraie vie c'est des
défenses qui vont être franchie à
l'occasion d'un phénomène extrême
exemple typique la nouvelle orléans
c'est le truc qui fallait pas qui va
faire passer la flotte par dessus la
digue qui va faire qui va rompre la
digue en question qui va et cetera qui
va noyer la centrale qui va enfin
n'importe quoi c'est ça qui va se passer
c'est par crise que les conséquences
vont se manifester c'est absolument pas
de manière continue être le truc qui
monte gentiment vous dis comme la marée
qui remonte sur une plage et puis envoie
le truc est arrivé trois ans à l'avant
sous cinq ans à l'as vence et puis on
demande gentiment aux gens de remonter
de 10 m c'est pas comme ça que les
choses se passeront donc il faut il faut
garder en mémoire encore une fois que ce
processus le est comment dire élan c'est
un peu comme la vieillesse 1
c'est long et c'est lent puis un jour ça
vous tue tout d'un coup c'est un peu
c'est un peu l'idée
que vous devez retenir c'est à dire que
les conséquences de cette élévation du
niveau des océans se traduiront et ça va
probablement être le cas pour
l'essentiel des conséquences du
changement climatique par crise c'est
probablement comme ça que les choses
vont se manifester
voilà qu'elle fait pour ceux qui veulent
et boissons pour les autres et quand
vous viendrez vous parlerai du gulf
stream